[Music]
on his voyage back he was captured near
the island of farmer kusa by pirates who
already at that time controlled the sea
with large armaments and countless small
vessels to begin with then when the
pirates demanded twenty talents for his
ransom he laughed at them for not
knowing who their captive was and of his
own accord agreed to give them fifty in
the next place after he had sent various
followers to various cities to procure
the money and was left with one friend
and two attendance among Silesians most
murderous of men he helped them in such
disdain that whenever he lay down to
sleep he would send and order them to
stop talking eight and thirty days as if
the men were not his Watchers but his
royal bodyguard he shared in their
sports and exercises with great
unconcerned
he also wrote poems and sundry speeches
which he read aloud to them and those
who did not admire these he would call
them to their faces illiterate
barbarians and often laughingly
threatened to hang them all the Pirates
were delighted at this and attributed
his boldness of speech to a certain
simplicity and boyish mirth but after
his ransom had come from Meletis and he
had paid it and was set free
he immediately manned vessels and put to
sea from the harbor of Meletis against
the robbers he caught them too still
lying anchor off the island and got most
of them into his power their money he
made his booty but the men themselves he
lodged in the prison of Pergamum and
then went in person to Junius the
governor of Asia on the ground that it
belonged to him as predator of the
province to punish the captives
but since the prayer tour cast longing
eyes on their money which was no small
sum and kept saying that he would
consider the case of the captives at his
leisure Caesar left him to his own
devices went to Pergamum took the
robbers out of prison and crucified them
all
just as he had often warned them on the
island that he would do when they
thought he was joking